bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors les auteurs du livre
blanc propose de porter le budget des
missions de sécurité à 1% du pib du pays
en 2013 ce qui représenterait un
triplement du montant actuel reste à
savoir comment cet argent supplémentaire
va être utilisé écoutez je suis entré
dans la police j'ai fait mes premières
démarches pour l'entreprise dans les
années 2005 à l'école à l'époque de
nicolas sarkozy depuis j'ai traversé une
alternance c'est à dire avec la gauche
les socialistes une autre alternance
avec emmanuel macron peut être une
quinzaine de mises de l'intérieur
écoutez pour moi c'est de la politique
politicienne c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement tout le monde rase gratis
si je puis dire bon effectivement moi je
vous dit 1% du pib en 2030 je veux dire
monsieur macron jusqu'à preuve du
contraire été élu jusqu'à 2022 donc vous
voyez l'idée le message subliminal
c'est le diable si vous roulez
effectivement on augmente les dotations
des ministres notamment des ministères
de l'intérieur et des finances et
falloir me réélire parce que si ça se
fait pas ce sera d'autres août parce
qu'on m'avait pas réélu we do c'est ce
qu'on appelle effectivement raser gratis
à l'aube des élections puisque la
campagne des présidentielles et des
législatives va commencer dans quelques
mois
écoutez on a eu exactement le même
phénomène en 2017 si vous souvenez des
manifestations des policiers en colère
manuel valls qui était premier ministre
a reçu avec monsieur 15,9 à l'elysée les
syndicats de police
on nous avait promis à l'époque une
enveloppe de 25 millions d'euros
oh ben moi j'ai envie de vous dire allez
à % du pib mais il aurait dû mener 2 5%
il n'y a pas de souci puisque de toute
façon ça n'arrivera pas vous savez ce
sont des effets d annonce une loi ça ce
vote mais ça peut aussi saab roger ça
peut aussi ne pas s'appliquer c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe pour 80% des
lois du code de procédure pénale
aujourd'hui puisque la loi n'est
appliquée nulle part nous c'est qu'une
loi de plus qui finira au fond d'un
tiroir
j'écoutais pour moi
à part faire de la politique
politicienne et spéculer à l'aube des
élections présidentielles et des autres
échéances électorales ça n'a strictement
aucun intérêt et la colère des policiers
l'époque de manuel valls est la même
aujourd'hui
non aujourd'hui les policiers ne sont
pas en colère ils sont caressés dans le
sens du poil puisque cette loi leur
prévoit justement une immunité
j'irai si je pouvais utiliser un
néologisme ce serait une ennemie une
immunité jacques beynel eastick si je
puis dire pour faire référence à ce qui
se passait dans l'ancienne tunisie de
ben ali
parce que si vous voulez le il ya eu
plusieurs phases c'est-à-dire connais
pas on vous disait effectivement que les
violences policières n'existait pas sa
propre eau qui a été réitéré par le
ministre de l'intérieur
au début dans les premiers jours de sa
nomination il n'y a pas de violences
policières ça n'existe pas c'est le
fruit de l'imagination peut sans doute
des victimes et bornés et mutilé qu'on a
pu voir et d'ailleurs c'était sans doute
de leur faute puisque l on créer du
trouble à au public et la police étaient
obligées de riposter de toutes ses
forces pour se défendre face à ces
manifestants très virulent vous savez de
dos qui a pas de violences policières
et puis quand on a présenté des victimes
et des morts comme il est vrai douanes
quand on a eu je devienne le gay etc
gpn a falsifié des rapports ça a été
prouvé aujourd'hui pour innocenter les
policiers mais effectivement la police a
été mise à mal son image a été écornée
par tous ces vidéos amateurs ces photos
qui ont été diffusées sur les réseaux
sociaux pas donc la solution au lieu de
réformer l'igpn au lieu de deux comme
mondial de doter les organismes de
formation de la police de moyens
supplémentaires pour pouvoir permettre
aux policiers d'accéder à une formation
de qualité on interdit la diffusion des
images c'est beaucoup plus simple c'est
beaucoup moins cher et c'est peut-être
beaucoup plus payant à courte échéance
vous parlez de la loi sur la sécurité
globale
juste un petit mot sur le
ce livre blanc qui affiche également la
volonté de repenser la communication
autour des forces de l'ordre pourquoi
selon vous la police jouit tel d'une
mauvaise image auprès de certaines
personnes
je suis pas sûr qu'elle en jouissent
malheureusement je pense qu'au contraire
c'est quelque chose qui est déplorable
mais écouter ce discours que je viens
d'entendre de monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur il ya un petit souci c'est à
dire que vous savez j'ai eu l'occasion
de prendre connaissance des éléments du
dossier de magnanville auquel il a fait
référence
l'art aussi à bala lorsqu'il a décidé de
d'assassiner nos deux malheureux
collègues
c'est à dire jessica schneider et jean
baptiste alevins il les a pas aperçu sur
une image de télévision ou sur les
réseaux sociaux leur adresse et leur
identité ont été exfiltrés par une
déléguée syndicale qui a hébergé chez
elle une amie de sa fille qui était
fiché est celle qui était en relation
étroite avec la mouvance islamiste
radicale
donc il faudrait peut-être que monsieur
darmanin prennent connaissance de ce
dossier parce qu'il n'a pas eue en a
apparemment pas la maîtrise
il se trouve que cette fonctionnaire de
police a été embauché par ma direction
c'est à dire celle qui m'a persécutés
pendant quelques années la direction
interdépartementale de la police aux
frontières et avant d'être sanctionné
par l'administration parce qu'ils
avaient une affaire judiciaire ne
pouvait pas ne rien faire on est obligé
de faire semblant de la sanctionner
elle a été promue au grade de major donc
c'est comme ça que la police fonctionne
aujourd'hui et si vous voulez la mois le
discours du ministre il me dérange parce
qu'il a un train en finalement
d'avaliser l'idée que la police
finalement doit avoir peur c'est à dire
que la peur ne doit pas changer de camp
mais que la police fit doit finalement
prendre des dispositions pour gérer en
quelque sorte matérialiser cette peur
qu'on peut avoir des différentes menaces
des voyous des terroristes des
harceleurs du net etc etc
moi je crois au contraire qu'il faudrait
justement tapé du poing sur la table
serrer la vis à toute cette délinquance
et toute cette criminalité qui rendent
la vie impossible à nos concitoyens et
que la peur puisse enfin changer de
corps mais moi il faut pas qu'on
m'explique comment est ce qu'on va
mettre en place des dispositions pour
que la police puisse avoir peur et être
fier d'avoir peur
on marche sur la tête monsieur merci
beaucoup nomment anwar d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
délégué syndical vigie police merci à
vous